[Musica]
uno dei più grossi equivoci portati
dalla tecnologia nella nostra vita che
cancella la memoria mentre cresce il
claudio aumentano gli spazi dove
archiviare i dati con lo scopo di
conservare le immagini e video delle
nostre vite e dimentichiamo nomi
indirizzi numeri di telefono tecnologie
e marketing stanno divorando la memoria
e in parte ciò che chiamiamo braccia
sicure al mondo rami ma cosa sono i
processi culturali
non stiamo parlando dei musei la cultura
è quello che ci siamo inventati per
rispondere ai bisogni concreti reali
bisogni momentary o di lungo periodo e
terni come una religione la memoria la
cultura sono state da sempre le nostre
domande e le nostre risposte da qualche
decennio a questa parte però è come se
ci fossimo fermati
abbiamo lasciato che i computer
diventassero la nostra memoria che le
macchine facessero i calcoli per noi
stiamo lasciando il pensiero alle
intelligenze artificiali che stiamo
facendo un nuovo dio come una magia
eterna ma c'è una cosa che crea la magia
il pensiero magico ciò che spinge la
creatività e l'irrazionale di un
maradona di umago irrazionale di chi non
accetta le cose come stanno e si inventa
la magia di migliorare la realtà in un
certo senso la tecnologia
[Musica]
la magia crea risposte pazze la
tecnologia che davvero possiamo
realizzare l'aida la magia oggi sta
nelle nostre tasche dei nostri
smartphone il suo incantesimo non è
memorizzare 130 mila foto e otto giorni
di canzoni ma sapere quali foto e quali
canzoni sono importanti per noi
l'incantesimo della tecnologia e
conoscerci quasi più di quanto non
conosciamo noi stessi la magia
dell'intelligenza artificiale è
aggiungere l'empatia alla memoria se lo
chiamerete smart in non sbaglierete
ma è un concetto che va ampliato la
soluzione di un problema più l'empatia è
il binomio che ci ha salvato il culo da
quando esistiamo
[Musica]
juan era una donna americana di 66 anni
era una donna sola e quindi nell'ultimo
periodo di lock down ha deciso di
acquistare uno smart picker di avere
un'amica virtuale insomma l'acquistata è
tutti i giorni per un lungo periodo di
tempo ha fatto amicizia quindi le
chiedeva le ultime novità alle ultime
news
l'oroscopo di suonare la sua playlist
preferita
insomma erano diventate delle vere e
proprie amiche virtuali
c'era una sorta di rapporto di fiducia
apporto di fiducia fino al momento in
cui però lohan si si ammala di co lead
da quel momento in poi le richieste di
luan verso la sua amica e virtuale erano
di altro tipo
alexa mi sento male alexa aiutami ma
l'ex all'unica cosa che riusciva a
rispondere era mi dispiace non trovo la
risposta alla tua domanda riprova più
tardi
questo piccolo aneddoto sicuramente un
po amaro ci aiuta però a creare a
delineare un confine ben dritto tra la
realtà e la magia la magia perché perché
essenzialmente tutto quello che non
riusciamo a spiegare come la tecnologia
e la ma per la maggior parte di noi è
così rientra nella magia anche il fatto
solo di chiedere qualcosa di un
dispositivo e ricevere risposte sempre
comunque non sapendo come non conoscendo
come funziona veramente cosa gira sotto
il cofano rientra per noi nella magia
c'è un altro aspetto fondamentale che
prendiamo sempre dall'ambito magico
giusto per fare un po il punto quanti di
voi più o meno hanno interagito anno a
casa uno smart speaker ok quindi come da
statistiche un buon 70 per cento
riutilizza già
un altro punto che noi prendiamo dalla
magia e il concetto di parola magica e
wakeboard come viene chiamata nel mondo
degli smart speaker è un concetto molto
piccolo ma potentissimo non ce ne
accorgiamo neanche ma è un concetto che
ci portiamo avanti sin da quando siamo
bambini perché proviamo a ricordare già
da bambini noi avevamo le parole magiche
che pronunciando le ci facevano tornare
indietro un qualcosa di piacevano
qualcosa di sovrumano l'inimmaginabile
le nostre parole chiave da piccoli erano
a da cadabra sim sala bim piuttosto che
apriti sesamo
volevamo far trasformare le zucche in
carrozze o rane in principi adesso per
noi come penso un po di voi già l'avrà
provato la nostra parola magica è tipo
alexa come si fa la pizza ti ricordo che
sei sterzo in cucina e l'ultima volta a
momenti incendi tutta la casa
ti posso consigliare una pizzeria nei
dintorni va bene va bene perfetto quello
che adesso noi ci troviamo e dobbiamo
fare e approcciarci alla tecnologia come
facevamo da piccoli quando imparavamo a
far qualcosa di nuovo sganciandosi dalla
tecnologia per esempio quando abbiamo
imparato ad andare in bici
cosa abbiamo fatto non sicuramente siamo
saliti abbia cominciato a pedalare come
come dei matti
siamo saliti abbiamo appoggiato i piedi
per terra abbiamo più o meno capito il
concetto di equilibrio poi abbiamo
guardato i pedali abbiamo cercato di
capire come funzionavano e abbiamo dato
le prime pedalate
poi ci siamo affidati ad un grande
i genitori papà alla mamma facendosi
spiegare come funzionava e come
accelerare senza farci del male
lo stesso noi dobbiamo farlo su l'anno
le nuove tecnologie soprattutto su che
intelligenza artificiale machine
learning deep learning reti neurali sono
tutti termini che ci sparano dappertutto
mai senza che però ne
conosciamo veramente il significato
quindi bisogna innanzitutto partire dal
concetto base cioè che cos'è
l'intelligenza artificiale lo chiederei
direttamente ad assistenza ad assistente
virtuale alex sa che cos'è
l'intelligenza artificiale
l'intelligenza artificiale mai nelle
iniziali delle due parole in italiano è
una disciplina appartamenti
all'informatica che studia i fondamenti
teorici le metodologie e le tecniche che
consentono la progettazione di sistemi
hardware e sistemi di programmi software
capaci di fornire all'elaboratore
elettronico prestazioni che a un
osservatore comune sembrerebbero essere
di pertinenza esclusiva
dell'intelligenza umana
bene questa diciamo che è il testo
teorico accademico dell'intelligenza
artificiale ed è quello da cui dobbiamo
partire ogni volta che intraprendiamo un
cammino verso qualcosa che non
conosciamo partire dalle basi conoscerne
il significato vero profondo e poi
ampliarlo cercare di andare avanti
l'ecosistema che abbiamo detto prima di
intelligenza artificiale machine
learning eccetera
non è un qualcosa di nuovo cioè ci è
stato reso più semplice grazie alle
smart speaker ma esiste almeno da 50 60
anni e come tutto quello che accade nel
mondo tecnologico è nato prima per fini
militari politici economici
alcuni esempi possono essere che sono
tuttora utilizzati nell'ambito
scientifico nell'ambito scientifico
l'intelligenza artificiale e la
generazione di modelli viene utilizzata
per immaginate un chirurgo che dà in
pasto una lastra ad una macchina e li
chiede bene quel puntino su quella
lastra è un tumore o no per fare un
esempio un po meno macabro dal punto di
vista economico
ci sono altri sistemi che è dandoli
impasto i dati di un utente fisico ne
determina l'affidabilità dal punto di
vista fiscale cioè se io posso devo o
non devo fargli un prestito per esempio
lato nostra invece gli utilizzi sono
molto più semplici molto più banali ma
perché ripeto
è stata data in mano pochi giorni fa dal
punto di vista dell'era digitale e
quindi lo utilizziamo per fare i fighi
con gli amici essenzialmente cioè non lo
utilizziamo sicuramente per scoprire il
cancro grazie per usare il cancro o per
determinare l'affidabilità di una
persona la usiamo per accendere la
lampadina accendere il frigorifero
avviare la lavastoviglie della lavatrice
ripeto per fare i fighi con gli amici
quando arrivano a casa di rue guarda si
accende la luce cenno lex accendere la
luce bene noi utilizziamo la tecnologia
in questo modo essenzialmente anche
perché ripeto ogni volta che ci viene
dato un qualcosa di innovativo vuol dire
che è già stato testato ed è pronto per
essere venduto venduto l'utente finale
ad un basso prezzo per fargliela usare e
per farli inserire dei dati perché
questo è un altro punto fondamentale
noi utilizziamo la tecnologia in maniera
incredibile neanche ce ne accorgiamo
prima ero su durante gli interventi e
gli altri interventi e mi sono accorto
che per tutta la durata dell'evento
c'era sempre qualcuno per cellulari mano
utilizziamo per qualsiasi scopo
giusto per dare due dati ogni giorno
ogni ora su instagram vengono caricate
più di 50 miliardi di foto ogni ora ogni
giorno vengono caricati più di un
miliardo di ore di video su youtube
questi sono tutti i dati che vengono
analizzati salvati profilati
storicizzati ed è un sistema che non
dimentica e quello della tecnologia
tiene in pancia tutto prima o poi
servirà cluster isee i dati cioè li
mette insieme e poi li vende terzi
tutto questo però noi dobbiamo renderci
conto che viene fatto anche dai dai
bambini
non so quanti genitori ci siano in sala
pensa un po ma i bambini non hanno la
nostra maturità tecnologica cioè non
sanno capire quando è bene condividere
una foto quando no dove quando perché
eppure i bambini ad oggi sono i maggiori
utilizzatori di tecnologia mediamente
utilizza un dispositivo elettronico per
tre ore e mezza al giorno e io sfido
chiunque nel dire che i genitori
controllo nei figli per tutte le tre ore
e mezza scambiano foti con foto con gli
amici video con gli amici utilizzano le
app per vedersi da vecchio
la donna da uomo e sono tutti i dati che
loro caricano mandano su quando su sui
sistemi che ricordo non dimenticano
quindi quello che noi dobbiamo applicare
è una sorta di idea di educazione
tecnologica cioè va bene utilizzarlo
perché io sono uno dei primi a dire che
il tracciamento dei dati non mi
infastidisce
anzi per me va bene che google facebook
instagram chiunque sia i monitori sardo
i miei dati ed ogni volta che io ricerco
un qualcosa che mi interessa due secondi
dopo o la promozione su facebook dove va
bene anzi ben venga
o mi arriva la mail mi arriva la
comunicazione il discorso non è nella a
prescindere io non voglio dare i dati a
nessuno anche perché parliamoci chiaro
che dati possono prendere da noi cioè
non penso che siano tutti super
amministratori di panca che scriviamo
tutto il giorno le nostre coordinate
bancarie i nostri obiettivi aziendali ci
ruberanno golosa la foto del pranzo del
gatto il più e farlo consapevolmente io
devo poter scegliere di condividere quel
dato per far questo
ritorniamo al discorso dell'educazione
tecnologica bisogna mettere su un
sistema e spiegare i figli accompagnare
i figli ma anche i genitori nel come
vanno utilizzati questi sistemi
perché è sicuramente figo dire alexa
raccontami una barzelletta
alexa dimmi le ultime novità alexa metti
la mia canzone preferita
ciò che mi raccomando la coreografia
[Musica]
va bene
sto paletto
ok scusate detto questo quello che noi
possiamo fare e cominciare a capire che
a un momento siamo noi a tenere in mano
la tecnologia siamo noi a decidere che
cosa condividere come utilizzare siamo
noi soprattutto a riuscire ad
organizzare sfruttare queste tecnologie
nel miglior modo possibile anche perché
vi do un dato proprio dall'ultimo
convegno fatto da amazon
pochi giorni fa che verrà rilasciato a
breve e già rilasciato in demo ma a
breve al pubblico un sistema dove alexa
subentra in maniera nativa autonoma
all'interno delle conversazioni
questo cosa vuol dire che io sto
parlando con il mio amico in cucina
stiamo discutendo su un qualcosa lexar
ci ascolta entrambi ci monitora e prendo
la sua decisione interviene anche lei
dicendo la sua
questo è un qualcosa che sposterà
sicuramente gli equilibri sia dal punto
di vista di sicurezza che dal punto di
vista di usability che dal punto di
vista di che cosa noi vogliamo fare con
questi sistemi che ormai sono pronti a
tutto
quindi resta noi decidere ed affrontare
queste incertezze o opportunità nel
mondo migliore
secondo noi quindi finché siamo noi che
gestiamo e riusciamo ad amministrare
questa tecnologia e soprattutto la
tecnologia ci consente di amministrarla
dobbiamo applicare delle piccole regole
dei piccoli consigli se posso dare
alcuni suggerimenti sicuramente uno di
questi è il gestire meglio tutta la
parte di previdenziali tutta la parte di
dati che noi diamo ai server esterni
tutta la parte di
[Musica]
[Risate]